elephant in the room and his friend to a
good joke oh right yeah Jordan as well
you gettin into your basketball who do
you support salt X I'll make us enemies
I like white and oh well that's what
I'll do then I miss all this fun okay
they definitely finish the sentence of I
like white otherwise I don't like white
and groove good
[Music]
Faye's banks quit YouTube Zoo you ever
lived in the cloud house or cuz they're
called cloud garden right what would we
call this just the flat
we're not [__] we go back to the
flat or do you mean the T G flat room
the TRO crew yeah yeah I'm so proud of
you switch the camera oh my god I feel
sorry for the people that want to
remember what the [__] we're on about
Paul Hercules and the hungry professor
as Stephen Chows would say know what
never kiss anyone going she's a
good-looking girl you should be more
grateful he lives in the cloud house and
he's got a lot of clout shoes as well
people love that word quote it's such a
[__] word in it it's like influenza he
said it's like the word tractor there's
no elegance to the word plow flow yeah
so happy to be making this video is
there a point that watching this it says
here look why I quit YouTube and so far
I'm sort of seeing why I mean he's
kicked out he's got a fit wife you know
let's just get stuck and is it fares
that's what he's known for the gaming
crew the clan is
yeah if you're living in North America
probably not good to close off the clan
join a join our clan the water it's
called the CCC it's the it's a cat cloud
cloud because let's face it guys you
guys are a huge part of our almost I'm
happy that they're happy what are we
watching this [__] video says why I
quit YouTube but I get the feeling
Millie it's a its clickbait I've been
click baited I wouldn't care that that
mom's basement podcast I got I quite
like that we heed Eman team did it he
actually can make some good stuff to be
federal Logan had a brain injury so what
are my prayers for my young stars dear
God don't let me be famous before my
brain is finished developing his fame
just does a whole number on have you
ever been treated for your brain I had a
skull fracture have a millimeter skull
fracture when I was in the seventh grade
anything that fractured her skull
generally hurts the right so her my
brains I have a titanium plate in my
head action
you suppose it's a lovely doctor warm
nice he's just says more prayer for all
famous people he's actually right though
you don't want to be famous before
you're ready for that [__] but that's
just basic you don't have to go to a
doctor a phone that oh yes fine is proof
I've got a [__] told you that ya
never get famous before your brain is
finished developing on the web my own
finishes I'm gonna be great I'm gonna be
great slash really [__] up no hives my
brain are missing but it's hurt and this
is really important because right here
is the most human when I go to the
doctor I'm also quite respectful as I
shut the [__] up I don't know if he's
acting yeah but I genuinely believe he's
in shock then yes letting the rest of
your life with this brain is not going
to be a lot of fun for you or for the
people who I'd love to just put a white
coat on and just go up to some people I
don't like and go living the rest of
your life with a brain like that is not
going to be a lot of fun I don't lot of
thick [__] I feel that way
about them yeah I mean I just want to
tell people I don't like that their life
is not gonna be a lot of fun he's with
the white corn you want to just be a
nasty dog I want to be a life coach
anything that hurts okay sighs fist yeah
what would be a good thing to do right
well probably not step in a [__] you
know ring and get punch to the head if
Logan didn't want to fight here so this
would have been the perfect way out was
very much funny that one so what he's
basically saying is remove high-risk
behavior remove alcohol remove drugs
from your life and your brain look like
I'm living through that you couldn't
what was it you wanted no fun at all
come on Brian we're all wearing jackets
in this jacket I actually believe is
giving you brain damage Logan's brother
just dropped the new music video
can I just also say that isn't how
medical cells are they don't give you
like a little page in the corner I'm a
really well nice lip room it's not like
that all right I know I just
I've seen these situations those I've
seen I got a tour going to no time isn't
but like for a YouTube guy I think he
makes all care tunes like he Tunes a
dear sir and the melody always does the
good melody lyrics could do with a bit
of work you know he's alright
considering he's an entertainer the
auto-tune could do were knocking down a
notch but I understand if he doesn't
probably rate his voice high enough you
know when you say he'd not the auto down
by not there's a reason people are
teaching there I get that you knocked it
down this is not bad for him this isn't
bad at all in my opinion if Drake did
this as a my album song everyone would
go brilliant wow this one's about
Rihanna 100% God's plan was not a great
song God's plan
God fred is nothing special if there's
beauty in simplicity brunch
[__] hell I don't know about you
teenage boy and listen to love songs
sometimes a bit because it's before
you've been hurt by anything real do you
know what I mean and you're like yeah
pain One Tree Hill I'll never follow you
never rejected by girls teenager not
definitely I just didn't think he'll
hurt that way so I remember once I asked
a girl why it was maybe you could yeah
cool and you know when you've got like
your winter-quarters applause you just
took their face and went a call when
weirdly she ended up going with a guy
for money after that Wow she bought the
wrong horse ladies and gentlemen let's
just leave it at that or maybe the right
one you know you've got a jacket off
doing all right yeah how many jackets is
he got ya idiot you've all seen this
mall more [__] now let's watch the video
just to be clear it's not real if
there's anyone who's young out there
watching I know if I was a kid and I saw
this stuff I'd be like wow this is the
way that Japanese people
Teresa may looks wow that's some dark
[__] I can't look her in the eye Wow
guys dark isn't it yeah I thought the
doll was gonna do something just a
picture just a picture with the girls
and it currently mainstream media are
making a big deal about it as if it's
safe well somebody please think of the
children so I think this is a real
problem actually is that mainstream
media sees anything on YouTube at the
moment and they go finally something
that take down the company that's
abusing our numbers yeah exactly
YouTube's uploading it deliberately to
kill all the children YouTube is the
devil yeah according to this story that
was being spread around people most
commonly teens and children can reach
Momo by texting a certain number on what
set the story saying most people don't
get a response from the number but if
you did it would start to send creepy
messages implying I know his personal
information about you and the story then
went on to say that moment would ask the
texture to do dangerous or violent
things including self-harm and to send
photographic proof has this challenge
which it was being called became popular
last July when it was deemed a hope he
just talked so fast and says so much
needless knowledge do you think like I
like Phil it's good I'm really getting
up-to-date but know that it's too much
info cut the [__] chase so mom or
this thing was on what's up [__]
people were texting it apparently but it
was all rubbish anyway that's not done
when you're talking about UFC you can
talk about for hours and you'll just go
so what if like a lion for like Jon
Jones what would happen and you're like
when it comes down to Momo it's like
whoa just cut to the [__] chase of
the three numbers people commonly
associated with Momo one was Japanese
one was Mexican and one was Colombia but
despite location she said that even the
Japanese number which was the most
popular could communicate in Spanish
which made it very common in
spanish-speaking countries I just saw
much needless info invasion I think I
think he just talks to you fast for your
it's denied your brain is not fully
developed that's the problem here movies
yeah there's a gamma rule if you see
Momo No Go Go it will put a couple of
[__] little inserts into children's
videos and claim that it was a big
[__] problem on YouTube it isn't snot
it's a horse it's bollocks
Choni who solves all your problems in a
black community in America if Michael
Jackson was the King at one point then
Oprah is the queen of a Shirley and if
she is siding with his accusers can you
explain to people why you want to
continue the Association if you have
been abused I had no understanding of it
being abuse you know I loved Michael
while never forgetting any of the sexual
details that happen between us but
having no understanding that it was
abuse having no concept in my mind that
anything about Michael could ever be bad
anything that Michael did was right to
me for so many years so many people have
accused Michael Jackson at this point if
he wasn't guilty this would be like a
world record of being accused by lots of
people and not being yeah yeah it's it's
highly likely that he did this in mind
and now even the people who denied it in
the pasta also actually now turn around
saying well yeah I just didn't have the
balls to say it back there no I grew up
loving Michael Jackson's music he's one
of the first artists that I loved
like I just remember watching the movie
that he made called moonwalk Aaron
Sherritt wow this is sick so it's sad
because all of these great songs are now
tainted you know I mean because you
think well this is this isn't you you
know he denied that he had plastic
surgery he denied bleach and his skin he
didn't know he denied so many things and
now don't get me wrong you can lie about
some stuff and not other stuff but
generally I just don't believe a word
that that man ever said now the parents
in many cases seemed away of what was
going on for them getting close to
Michael Jackson and the money and the
superstar was worth it to some of these
parents and that really [__] me up that
does that make those people about people
or does it make them that doesn't make
them you know no but does it make them
naive and taken him by a lie do you feel
sorry I don't give a [__] whether you
knew what was going on you have taken
your child have a sleepover at a 40 year
old man's house you are a [__] idiot
ready for this admittedly here's your
sauce info so on I had all these
demonically possessed he heard r.kelly
speaking of demons boys and this is not
as
actual thing this is a satanic thing I
mean you know that the fact that this is
still being debated I mean we've heard
this our whole life what are they
waiting for
it's 2019 I don't care if you're priests
or not imagine midway through a piece
about pedophiles and demonic possession
showing a picture of the Pope and then
also just kind to Alex Jones go ahead Oh
God producers look a bunch of that
budget shop you don't still picture Pope
with child mixed to our Kelly's face and
a picture of a demon from the Bible
faith and I'll explore further the
further and fade up from Alex Jones and
down for the next look at this suave
journalist who's calling this in who
they've labeled mine coal there is
something demonic thought about this and
I do care what they means anything to
get out of this man having to take
responsibility for this
oh no it was the My Little Ponies that
he had they made him do it
it's [__] responsibility you're a
man I want to say ancient times it was
viewed as like a form of devil worship
type [__] where they sacrifice children
or not there's something to do with
devil worshipping and children whenever
these conspiracy theorists come out and
say royal family are demonic or theirs
they always say although the children
will go and missing there's always
children yeah but to be absolutely clear
the devil is an analogy the devil's not
a real thing I'm sort of open-minded
about that source stuff I don't about
the devil the devil isn't the character
on South Park the movie in always with
Saddam Hussein but an evil are more like
energies that call within people and we
all have good and bad in us do you know
I mean that's what I don't I'm all good
but I think when people are purely evil
and very bad that to say they were
possessed by the devil is it sounds very
literal and that's where they sound so
stupid I think it's an easy get out when
you've done something wrong well yeah
yeah we just joined in this together
yeah or Kelly wrote a song for Michael
Jackson what was this song you're the
best pedophile I look up to you you are
not alone you and cost it up
oh how creepy would that be if you were
the victim of Michael Jackson and then
you listen to a song that's like you
know it's like Momo Michael Jackson look
a lot label the mic the my my challenge
me Michael I'm here to make you wanna go
to sleep again
Michael Jackson elsewhere in 90s artists
sorry 2000s artists ja Rule did some
stuff at the basketball
they say this is ninety tonight so they
brought out of two thousand artists
that's so David Brenner
I like the vote oh no he's right I just
want all of you not the know I'm not
that old I would have really loved it if
someone went who are you who am i who
are you mate
Oh God
I like ja Rule and you play a lot of
general music recently because you like
him he just brings back good memories of
being young yeah he made good sounding
songs like they were just stuff like you
could listen while drive or not in the
club it didn't have to be like too
intense you know out like Rattlers have
good runs so like Drake right now
Kanye early on like 50 cent had a run
like nobody else ever had like when he
came out everything he touched was like
old yeah you could not stop him that's
because he's all with Dre in Eminem it
didn't matter who went up against him he
would have killed anyone's career at
that moment it just so happened that it
was Jarrell who suffered I would like to
have him on the podcast I'd loved him on
yeah yeah he seems like a nice guy as
well yeah he dominated the charts for a
long time people don't understand that
oh you know it's even worse if I really
feel like this is like life on the road
yeah at one point in us ja Rule wasn't
it Bretton that huge he's he's a bit
like a Wiz Khalifa or someone like that
level of rapid you know what I mean but
bigger
but yeah but like he's in Boca he's in
people's hearts but we're never gonna go
he's your favorite he's not gonna be a
favor but he dominated the nightclubs
boost absolutely yeah yeah and the worst
thing about this whilst he's performing
the biggest player right now and the
hottest player in the NBA
gianna Santa to come bow came out starts
just shooting shots look they just I
just feel so full rule because I got
left up by the crowd yes even worse
though when all the players from the
team over half the team come out and go
yet is over now mate we've talked in the
past about how advertisers gear
differently towards men and women
obviously the last chili ad was
basically tellement gone to bad stuff
because that's what you guys usually do
right I think they were going we have a
reputation for doing bad things so
remember the good yeah we're the best of
men can give Gillette be better because
you lot of [__] I think a lot of it was
a bit like I think some beta males took
it that way if I'm completely honest
guys in the advertising they were
highlighting how bad men are capable of
being a lot in that ads right and my
point was with women it is very much the
exact opposite of that there was a lot
of debate in the comments I'm all right
I'm all wrong let's check out nice new
outlet just be clear
nice to you up just saying this though
you enjoy that debate you're not there
going I'm right you're wrong don't
debate me no let's check up nice Stewart
yeah I enjoy my counsel if we show
emotion we're called dramatic if we want
to play against men we're nuts and if we
dream of equal opportunity delusion
because women do great things but
they're often not appreciated for that
you see that Lawrence do you think when
we stand for something
we're unhinged when we're too good
there's something wrong with us what
we're seeing examples of right now is
all of the great things that women often
do brilliant brilliant you run that
marathon doing amazing amazing that was
amazing
I remember this name they can do that
you get the idea so this is all the
great things that women could to be
banned that was great and can I just say
quite proven like what do you mean to
the Geordie one-nil what are you saying
what I'm saying is is that men in
mainstream media today I talked to
completely differently to women and
these two adverts just proved my father
just a question do you think that
because Gillette made number that was
negative two men Nike have to bear the
brunt of making a good advert for me I'm
sick of how men are spoken do by
advertisers and how women are spoken do
by advertisers are great that I think is
fantastic yeah that's not the point I'm
making here
women are [__] pushed up to the moon
and built up and men are often knocked
down you know just because the way the
world used to be it's not necessary any
more men have rolled over and died you
know me we're quite happy for we're
happy for it to be equal I think I'm
happy to be well your people so when I
say the night dad
I thought wow I got goose bumps when I
watch a dad it was good [__] amazing
arena one of the greatest athletes ever
right so this is what I was on about
when I said that Gillette had right
[__]
yeah he said oh yeah women are expected
to wear makeup I'm like you're missing
the point it's the way used or talked to
by advertisers different than men and
that Nygaard and
let's prove what the [__] I was soon let
us know in the comments what do you
think because we need the interaction us
for make good job
that's way was it well then I was a
great hard I wasn't good at got no
problem with it
weekend getting ready what for I've seen
a bit of this before let's yeah alright
here we go
[Music]
the upstage the cinque say men can do
anything to proved it proved it right
[__] you in your [__] and you're a stun
said we can do it too he's such an
awkward looking cod no Eddie
wow I think they'll be fun to learn how
it does say that with the woman though
is that what you want to do yeah maybe
maybe if there's any woman out there who
can done say that I want to show me for
educational purposes only
this man has hips like a hope store my
lord right I can't serve but I'd love to
be able to all right so thing scares me
probably cause of [__] like this oh my
god like look how huge must that wave be
that is amazing that is deadly isn't it
now it's just gonna crash that is
scarier yeah because that could kill you
basically saw this thought of you a lot
of doing setups in it little Instagram I
follow up about animals who they hunt
each other and stuff I think we're
watching different instagrams I'm just
yeah what should watch one of the ones
that's been blurred there they are just
eating the carcass of a baby well to me
I think people get a sweet and innocent
side of nature in their head of all the
little monkeys
it shows what would really be going on
if you've seen them in their own
environments Krissi bangs been going to
church house you punk still involved in
the news we stay as a relevant this is
the clip that made me like cry laugh let
me just watch
it's the feet it's the feet that I'm
amazed I imagine you're doing your
normal weekend church by nowhere some
chris eubank
it's just standing in the middle of you
just going my lord come by how weird
would that mean take me [__] TV
license and be a [__] camera crew to
follow that man 24 cent all the time
when he has a [__] I wanna know avoid if
he dances in a [__] church I want a
normo keep much of the day yeah and give
Christmas like a TV show that's it I
want to see him chasing criminals down
in America with his little police badge
on no police badge in this picture so
he's got it was probably put away
because it'll scare people in church I
felt it away because otherwise people
will be scared around dancing this rat
got so fat that it could no longer fit
through the rain in the street and so
he's got stuck a little code that's
called natural selection wait for it
that's how fat he was underneath just
stomp on it okay I must be scared
witless he got so fat [__] protein
shake when they came along he went
what's going on it's the true rat it was
a guy who's skateboarding into the Grand
Canyon but he didn't quite make it this
is Bob Burnquist I love Bob Burnquist
he's a heroic skateboarder my look
didn't make it imagine falling into the
Grand Canyon like that or die no no
state alive he's absolutely fine
how the [__] did he stay alive parachute
that's affirming what men can do because
a woman would never be yeah woman would
never do that [__] yeah now a phenomenon
that's occurred around true news hashtag
do it with me true news but not a
hashtag don't forget to hashtag it
hashtag true news sitting car park at
high cross I love it
this man has not seen food reviewer yet
he's doing the food reviewer Act people
ask me to do reviews and when I get
around to do them I do do them listen
I've been meaning to do things and when
I do things I do them more literally you
though Wow
waiting for quite a while I've been
walking around through the video he just
cleans the sway of his enemy in front of
us goes okay
big not only looking like one but
sweating on hashtag relatable what you
do is you go in and you order what you
want obviously and you love him I've met
people like this before oh yeah totally
I've met so many men like you I got a
feeling his his eating habits are going
nefeli
see how he does food reviewer eyes I
just doesn't I don't know you managed it
there you go
or like a big old bite for Leicester
City five guys studying what I what do
you think jennifer lopez's
this is food Rubio's dad yeah he went to
America once [__] a woman Natalie
who's never yeah
and that's what's happening with the
food of you have uncovered a I've
uncovered a goldmine this is a chair
right yeah finally we've got a new food
review I will have to leave I Got News
for you oh [__] off I got a message from
him from someone else about him Katie
gee I was browsing food reviewers feed
please go and check out food reviewer
classic fruit gushers he is younger and
if possible more likeable he did
something we didn't know about this is
like when the Egyptian tombs were opened
oh my god take a [__] bow whoever
send me that Michael Jackson was nowhere
near him he wouldn't have even kept his
Hobbs no it's true
this is the food review that I used to
know before the channel went it's his
little face month you just want to
squeeze those chick he's even got so
much look at his little I like them
Kwanzaa and enjoy yourself
fruit gusher some nice London egg
actually can I say it this is what he
used to be like when he goes mm-hmm
listen there we go what my funeral can
you shut this up for me right I just
like the fact that some guys got a glass
thing on his van sure and girls dancing
this man is trying to kill people
possibly here look at that Brian you
would die if you saw this on the road I
probably would yeah especially
that whether karma sponsoring 2news
once again yet again thank you very much
calm because you who supported last time
said you had a future in a good
experience something I use and so when
Brian told me about it I was very happy
to hear [__] we were just saying it
for the money no and so if you go to
calm calm forward slash Geordie that's C
ALM calm /jh or door do then you get off
yeah and you support yourself and
obviously get 25% of comprar mean which
I have to attest is good the other night
Stephen Fry read to me as I fell asleep
I'm not even joking yeah that is a
pretty decent thing I would if it want
me to read for them and do you think
your voice is calming another kind of
Justice evening there's a little story
here for you it certainly beautiful town
known as Newcastle lovely in the town of
Newcastle you can find many things but
in one part there's a lot of bad things
okay I don't think again it's a car map
it's something where people are sort of
calm down meditation yeah you are on the
road there what do you think of when you
want to be calm I mean I've got some
I've got a few things the app suggests
here you can do guided meditations for
issues like anxiety stress focused they
don't make you make that noise but I've
got to say I was doing it this morning
and the woman's voice is so calming I
mean I thought that initially but you
know when you're sitting there in juice
or yeah you tense it quite a lot and you
realize how you hold all these things
all day it's a positive out it's yeah
it's not one of those apps where it's
like you know I look at me all the time
you can just go to it a couple of times
a day and if you you know if you've got
anxiety or stress isn't it stressing you
out in your life don't do what the
Americans do which is just pop pills
tyramine try something like this to
start with and then if that doesn't work
consult the doctor it was the number one
app last year and it helps with sleep
meditation and relaxation so we've
helped you out and calm have helped you
out 25% already feel better just talk
you know what I mean so thanks calm calm
calm forward-slash Geordie 25% off calm
premium well worth a look what was it
yeah another way of the week another
true news lots of food lots of crime and
some strippers if you've enjoyed it hit
the like button subscribe thanks for
watching and we will see you later
now time for pokes